i think from day one
it's a game changer you know it's the
ability to detect diseases before they
become symptomatic that is you know i
think that in in the past whatever 200
years
we've kind of changed our perception
about our bodies has changed you know
our health
is the doctor's responsibility it's not
our responsibility anymore
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
health is rapidly changing all around us
the digitalization of health is
exponentially growing and the consumer
behavior that is adapting to this change
is just fascinating and this is exactly
what this episode is about
meet guy goldman the ceo and founder of
olive diagnostics 100 passive continuous
urinalysis sensor that mounts to any
toilet and can be used to early detect
thousands of diseases
prior to establishing olive guy was the
ceo of a number of technology and data
science companies most recently i was
managing a large transportation service
provider company in london
of the data science companies guy
pioneered the advancement of churn
modeling for telecom companies and
software licensing optimizations both
companies were bought out one by a
publicly traded company on nasdaq a guy
holds a bs in computer science from the
university of san francisco
i'm really looking forward to speaking
with you about you know technology
medicine telehealth digitalization with
healthcare and and everything in between
the work that you're doing with all of
diagnostics i think it's you know it's
it's so cool in today's world to have
organizations and companies that are
that are looking at the healthcare
system that are looking at us you know
humans and and thinking through
technologies that will allow us to
get the help that we needed
accessibility
better technology to diagnose and to
treat and so thank you very much for the
work that you're doing but specifically
for coming here now and talking about it
and tell me a little bit about you know
yourself you've worked in quite a few
organizations leading up to
all of three diagnostics what's
happening there
yeah okay so um so i was uh i was moved
to israel as a kid and uh
upon finishing the military and
everything i went back to the united
states to study and i finished my uh i
graduated in uh
san francisco state
um i studied computer science and
physics and uh was kind of on that path
for a technology kind of uh career
but fairly early on i pivoted and
understood that the real money is in
sales um and so i moved over to sales
and then into management
and um
i was kind of managing you know people's
companies i was like a ceo for hire kind
of thing
and that's actually where the story of
all of diagnostic uh actually begins
because um what happened is i was uh
i was
imagining a really large company in
london and i was doing kind of this 10-4
rotation between israel and london so
back and forth back and forth
and um one day i get this call from my
mom who's living here in jerusalem in
israel i'm located right now in
jerusalem
and she tells me that she's been
diagnosed with ovarian cancer
and you know so your whole life flips
around then how can it be you're so you
know you run and you play tennis and how
can that beat
so whatever so she did a few surgeries
then she started chemotherapy and i
don't know anything about
chemotherapy the only thing i know about
chemotherapy is the big bad side effects
you know and i find myself calling home
three to four times a day
to ask you know whoever was watching her
that day like you know how's she doing
you know is she eating is she drinking
is she walking and she's sleeping just
you know the basics because i'm waiting
for these bad side effects to take place
and um my brothers and sisters here in
israel you know um
they kind of said to me look it's it's
great that you that you know it's
heartwarming the care and all that kind
of stuff but um
either come back to israel or stop
calling but something has to change now
you know because i was driving them now
you know
and what happened was
i started saying okay well
london's awesome i don't know if you
spend any time there so it's a fantastic
place
and i didn't want to come back to israel
there wasn't any rush to come back so
i'm like okay fine you know what it's
2017.
so there must be a technology that i can
put to kind of you know monitor her from
from a distance not i don't want to get
blood test results and stuff like i'll
understand that stuff right i just want
to know the basics
and um
you know it's 2017.
there should be something there you know
it's not 1986 what do we have right but
there should be something there so i
start going i'm starting to look and
look and explore and explore and explore
and there's nothing out there the only
thing that was closest were you know
these those you know watches smart
watches and i get footsteps and heart
rate which is good but it's not what i'm
looking for
and um that was that my dad got sick so
i came back to israel
and um
and decided that this is crazy because
anyone who's my age has parents who are
you know plus minus their age and i hope
everyone's healthy and stuff but you
know a lot of them aren't
and this problem of being able to just
you know just to know what's going on
is probably a huge problem i know i
faced it
and um
i always say that
in order for technology
you know to skip over the evolutionary
curve right so you have an evolutionary
curve of technology you know you got
your emails and you got them on your
computer then to your phone and to your
watch you know that's evolutionary
but for something to skip over there's
got to be a really really personal deep
reason why someone had to invent this
technology you know
and olive diagnostic with its
sensor that mounts onto a toilet
and allows for continuous
urinalysis five to seven times a day
we're introducing a new science to the
world not just a technology it's a
science that we had to to develop to
overcome the
tremendous amount of uh of noise that's
you know inherent in the system
so um
i guess that's a long introduction of
who i am but it kind of
you know so when you're looking at
the both on the consumer behavior front
as well as the scientific front right i
mean you have a few different things at
play here
because
you know there was a way to continue to
get updates but with your mom but it
resulted in you know not such a good you
know experience for for the different
parties right and at the same time
you're saying well even that i'm not
even sure like even if i do get her the
you know blood test whatever i'm not
sure that i can even read that i need
something that will be you know halfway
and so
how do you think strategically through
the through the solution so when you're
coming initially to all of diagnostics
and you're thinking okay
this is the solution that i want to
to
enable and to embed how are you shaping
your priorities at that point
so the priorities were really set as you
say
on
and and the whole device is designed
around a 74 year old woman
okay
so
my mom with all due respect isn't going
to change anything in her life to
appease or nourish my curiosity you know
she's not going to do anything you wanna
know call me
you know that's the kind of person she
was which is fun i think a lot of people
are like that you know
so really when we when we designed and
prioritized the feature set and the the
look and feel and the um the way the
device is installed it's all designed
for a 74 year old woman
to be able to install it and operate it
and use it by herself you know and um
there's a lot of features and when you
kind of get into the deep depth of it
you start to realize all these little
noises that you need to account for you
know
um forget the use cases that aren't that
you know right you know they use it for
anything so you gotta really really kind
of design it with that persona in your
head
and she's the one who's going to use it
fantastic
take me back to the initial prototype
you're creating the initial device
you're going to the market what are you
what are you trying to prove initially
what are sort of the assumptions that a
company like all of diagnostics has to
prove necessary to investors to the team
to yourself
that this
this thing is actually working
so that's a really funny story because
when i first started this somewhere in
2019 when i came up with this wild idea
of using optics to to do
molecular analysis
um
the the one of the advantages of israel
is so small
i went to all the universities and spoke
to all the optic professors you know
and all them thought i was absolutely
crazy to try to do what's called
spectroscopy it's the science behind the
technology
uh to do spectroscopy in an open
environment
because if you go and see a spectrometer
a spectrum use like this huge machine
it's a million dollars and you put a
test tube inside a box and you close the
box you put in this machine you seal the
machine it's completely silent you know
and also i'm like yeah i'm gonna put on
the back you know on the side of a
toilet you know they thought it was
absolutely crazy
and then the ones who kind of said like
yeah maybe there's a chance
but the minute i said yeah we're
actually
doing the measurements when the urine is
vertical we're doing it horizontally in
mo you know it's in motion and there's
ink to the to the drops are going to be
whatever shape they want to be you know
i just got laughed out of almost every
single room you know
so when you ask what do we need to prove
we need to prove
that this was scientifically possible
it's like if i told you okay can you
build me a time machine right you have
to prove the science that the science
works and
um we've had huge tremendous scientific
breakthroughs you know and one of the
things that we like to say but people
really
get it
is we took the optics
out of spectroscopy
so we we've gone so far out
that you know
yes we're using spectroscopy but it's
it's on this it's you know
it's it's something else you know
and so
and i have to prove it you know to first
of all to the investors and stuff like
that which was really difficult because
if you don't get deep into the equations
it's hard to see it's going to work
right right um
but then i had
you know anyone i tried to uh
to recruit
you know thought it was crazy i'm sure
there were a bunch of us crazy guys who
kind of got together and said well wait
a minute let's give it a shot you know
and
it hit in hebrew there's a word called
kutzba
you know
and our hood spies that we tried
because it was against
everyone's best judgment but we tried it
and it worked
um
it took us probably about a year to get
to an actual prototype or a proof of
concept
yeah that you can actually detect
using light
you know molecules because
molecules are so small you can't imagine
right
um
took about a year to do that then it
probably took up another year to to
get the spread so
the person just urinates doesn't matter
where they urinate doesn't matter they
don't have to do anything my mom's not
gonna do anything she's not gonna turn
on or off the light or anything like
that you know
and um it took us about another year to
get all the kinks worked out
and now we have a device that we're um
we're starting uh um operations sales
already in the european markets um mid
april it's going to be launched wow
a hundred
elderly homes
so that's incredible hundred and six
and at the so the phase that we're at
right now right where the phase where
you're saying okay we've built this
product we
we think we understand the consumer
behavior we think we
we get the value proposition and that
we're making it happen now you're sort
of on the route to find product market
fit right and and so what is this you
know this next 100 households what what
is the the most important thing you want
to learn
from
from the deployment of these units
honestly
just that people are okay with seeing on
their toilet with this device as simple
as that
i don't need any i don't need anyone to
tell me if i'm detecting stuff or not
that we know that we've done it a
billion times over
just that people aren't afraid to sit on
the device
wow i love it so you say so i love those
the you know the fact that you're
narrowing it down and you say okay we i
don't need them to tell me that it's
providing them you know analytical value
i just need to know that they're willing
to use it not for the science saying
just in terms of their human behavior
their their day to day
i think that's really really cool and i
really do love that seeing their toilet
and looking at their toilet the same way
for you know 70 80 years
and all of a sudden there's this new
thing on the toilet
you know
for some that might be a little bit like
wait what's this you know and i just
want to make sure
you know that uh that that works
so how are you envisioning this you know
down the line so once this becomes a
full-fledged product and it's and you're
you're taking it outside of you know
your own control how do you imagine it
getting to people's households and how
do you how do you grow this thing at
scale
great that's a good question
so our initial market and it didn't it
didn't actually happen i mean it didn't
happen purposefully this way so when we
started our company and and we had
funding stuff like that we started doing
a lot of market research to figure out
and there are so many verticals for this
product you know from sports and
nutrition to
safety at work law enforcement you know
you name it and that everyone needs and
we know because we're getting you know
we're getting
pushed from the market on almost every
you know we have like 15 or 20 verticals
that each one's a three four five
billion dollar market you know
um
and then we did all this analysis and we
figured out that we're actually going to
do you know um elderly remote
monitoring you know which was kind of
the the basis of the product and the
initially that's where we started from
but
once we circled back and we found out
that's actually our lowest hanging fruit
because we can provide the the easiest
most articulate
message
to a b2b sale so it's not even b to c
it's b to b we sell it to the assisted
living facilities so they put in that
you know
right
okay good
okay so you're just telling me you're
just talking about the strategy
for working with the on the b2b versus
b2c and and the different you know pros
and cons in that regard
right so
um so initially we're going after the
elderly population we we believe that we
get the biggest bang for our buck there
um plus it's a b2b sale versus the b to
c cell
uh what we're doing for them is we're
actually doing early disease detection
so you know if you think about a 78 year
old woman who gets a uti or you know a
90 year old guy with kidney stones
they go to the hospital it's not like
just something you know they go to the
doctor because right they had
20 or 30 symptoms you know from you know
fever and they're dizzy they can't walk
and they can't eat you know
so but by being able to continuously
monitor someone you can actually
pick up the disease before the symptoms
appear
okay and that's really what our we're
coming out with the uh with the first
device but like i said there's some
special unique qualities to this device
that makes it more appealing for someone
older than someone younger okay
so now we're going through um a
mechanical and industrial design of our
next
you know our next version
which is it's just a clip-on you just
clip it onto your toilet you know so for
younger people people who stand when
they urinate versus sitting down near
any because there's some there's some
issues there
um
and there we want to go a lot more into
the
you know the health monitoring slash
wellness
you know so sports enthusiasts who were
looking to see how well they worked out
looking to see how their
pre and post workout you know how their
bodies reacting to their workouts
you know
alcohol levels are you drinking too much
or you know so it's
it's everything associated with that if
you're thinking about you know when this
will become a game changer how does that
look how does how does all diagnosis
become a game changer for humans you
know around the world
so i think from day one
it's a game changer you know it's the
ability to detect diseases before they
become symptomatic that is
it's it's a it's
you know i think that in in the past
whatever 200 years
we've kind of changed our perception
about our bodies has changed you know
our health
is the doctor's responsibility it's not
our responsibility anymore you know so
if you want to get i don't know you want
to get an x-ray right you can't just go
and
buy an x-ray you know get an x-ray done
you have to go to a doctor who gives you
you know um a
prescription for an x-ray you know so
hope it's the doctor who does everything
it's not you we've lost contact with our
own bodies
and i think from day one this is kind of
giving us back that power to know what's
happening inside our bodies without
having to go through the whole doctor
and all that kind of stuff we can just
get it
right in front of us you know
um
we also believe that this is because of
doing early disease detection versus
symptomatic detection
right huge you know it's a huge change
that everything changes you know
preventative medicine and all those kind
of things you know um although we don't
like to say preventative because we're
not preventing it we're just catching
early you know um
but it's early curing which is much
cheaper and you know
the lifestyle
of of that is just you know huge
i love it guy thank you very much for
for coming here and for sharing the
story and the work it's really
fascinating and
and i'm sure it will do so good for the
world and for so many people that are
using it and i love the specifically the
intentionality behind
you know at the end they just need to be
able to be willing to sit on it right to
be able to sit on the toilet and not
feel like this product is not for them
to use on their day-to-day this is you
know there's there's a ripple effect of
what happens there's a chain reaction
what happens with the product right
after they use it but for for this to
work they just need to be willing to sit
exactly and and i just love that
understanding and that statement so guy
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you thank you and
uh it was really good being the call
[Music]